Liquor stores are selling beer and tequila in bulk in the run-up to Cinco de Mayo.
The annual celebration of all things Mexican,...
...which seems to get bigger every year in the US,...
...commemorates the Mexican army's victory over invading French forces...
...at the Battle of Puebla on May 5th, 1862.
Mexico's defeat of the French had consequences in the US...
...as it helped stymie Napoleon III's support...
...for Confederate forces in the Civil War.
Cinco de Mayo is celebrated more widely in the US than in Mexico,...
...where it's mainly marked in the state of Puebla.
Blowout nationwide patriotic celebrations in Mexico...
...come on September 16th aka Mexico's Independence Day.